and start the show ah [ __ ]
welcome back to another episode of
[ __ ] feelings this is for the
down and outs
for the bombs for the left alones the
divorce guys the divorce gal
you're sitting in your apartment out by
the airport this is the show for you
gang welcome back to another exciting
episode
of them hard [ __ ] feelings hang
on
hello hard feelings we got em you want
em hold please
[Laughter]
i'm your host holy crap i'm a road
starts playing got my life
in two pieces this is my pizza remember
that whole [ __ ]
uh kippy kevin james ryan is here with
us thank you they know who i am
you don't know me at the ten or twenty
dollar level body i don't know what's
going on check them out at the blackjack
table over there at the [ __ ] all right
get the cards out of your hands before
you get distracted by the way this is
the last pack of cards
hit me on the low all right stop that's
you're making noise um
what the [ __ ] was i gonna say oh uh like
evanescence
yeah and all that stuff god that was
trash
sure i mean you know you were older for
it i'm not saying it was good but i'm
just saying like that'd be like me being
like these [ __ ]
b2k kids or what you know what's b2b
okay speak uh
the kids that killed people and that's a
murderer that was that was about btk
yeah bkts the korean kids
the k-pop stars speaking of uh murderers
did you see that documentary on the girl
that disappeared at the cecil
hotel in l.a i have not no scary stuff
scary stuff that was very like dennis
miller of you scary stuff right here
wild whacky stuff this guy would cut you
up
then kill you um
welcome to hearth feelings everybody uh
i got a couple
this week want to kick it off right now
uh before i get into the big stress
test the nuclear test okay
which i filmed some video but i filmed
it the wrong way i saw
yay i filmed it straight up and down you
can't fix stupid you just can't there's
no answer for it
i mean you can't buy smart kids he
claims he's the head of content he's
sending me upside down videos what am i
supposed to do with this
he's doing selfies with the camera on
the back of that he's turning it
i can't see myself um before i get into
that
a little bit of a bone to pick with my
boy out there at the [ __ ] juice spot
by my apartment
they also saw frozen yogurt um which i
usually frequent
if you're not into euro tart frozen
yogurt i get down to a pinkberry or
whatever you got in the neighborhood
man that's a [ __ ] good time and it's
locale
um we got a juice place that we go to to
get treats
at night we go down and we get a little
frozen yogurt um
just dark chocolate and some
strawberries on top i get the big boy
um sneaking in skittles like it's a
movie theater
put a burger on the bottom cover it up
so my girl don't see
anywho so my lady was feeling a little
bit under the weather
um yesterday sure because we had a
little bit of a covey scare
last week so familiar so we had to uh we
had to go go get tested
um and we we slogged up there on super
bowl sunday which it was snowing
we walked up thinking that it was just
going to be the regular wait in line and
get a thing but it turns out they
switched over
to uh making reservations um
making reservations for two by the blood
pressure machine please
try the specials but uh so she got a
little sniffies from that
okay obviously we were worried it was
covey but we came back negative and then
you and i got tested
uh yesterday so we're both cleaning the
whistle
anywho um in the whistle whistle i don't
know
whistles are clean right sounds like
they took a peek down your pee hole
cleaning the whistle get a pipe cleaner
in that thing
kid's got a burner anywho so we have
this regular guy that we go to
that we get our we get our yogurt from
and we'll get a juice every once in a
while acai bowl you know
whatever you know nice day sure i'm
listening um
i break this guy off like a green grocer
[ __ ] you know tip him boom boom
boom he got his videos for you takes
good care of us
so i go in there to get my lady a
[ __ ]
uh pineapple straight pineapple juice so
she feels better okay i'm gonna surprise
her
he uses the pineapple that's a surprise
with a half empty pineapple juice
hey i know yeah i know you say i'm too
good too good to you but here you go
touch that hair's for you
then mommy when you got it but he gives
me the pineapple that's all chopped up
in the
in the little uh frozen yogurt buffet
where you put your toppings on
okay just like in a cup no he no he used
that he went and got the you know the
thing that that's in
where i would go in and scoop it from
the from the accessory bar
he used that and put that in the juicer
and the juicer yeah it was like liquidy
i don't understand the difference here
instead of cutting up a fresh pineapple
and putting it in the juice he took the
[ __ ] that was out for other people other
people had been dipping into it other
people are dipping during coven
you're going to like communal toppings
bars they have it out
shift gears big man what kovi can get on
on pine nappies
i don't know i wouldn't be doing it new
york said different would you eat at a
hot bar
you wouldn't need a hot bar new york's a
different place post kovit dude you
can't be do
using communal toppings i don't know man
you know i like a nice hot bar
man i know it a little [ __ ] teriyaki
chicken some mac and cheese and mashed
potatoes
man that's a combo yeah that's fusion
right there
yeah you can get whatever a little down
home little [ __ ]
far east seafood salad whatever you need
are they gonna come back
ever because i'd have hard feelings with
that if they never come back they're
bad i mean there's one not too far
there's one in midtown that i have no i
don't go there but it's there
it's limited you know selection i tell
you people split in town man this place
is looking real
dumpy that's [ __ ] they're porting
down a [ __ ] tampa
i'm [ __ ] waiting for a coffee test
yeah
win the super bowl maybe you can party
what the [ __ ] have you done still got
two years eligibility left
get back dog
hard feelings um so that bothered me
about that a little bit you know what i
mean i thought you said you had stuff
i do it guys use it it's fresh cut
pineapple no it's not
fresh cut pineapples fresh cut pineapple
i'm in there breaking you off [ __ ] a
20
dip every time i [ __ ] get yogurt
i'm expecting some [ __ ] premium
service don't you hate that when the
bottom drops out on you you think you
have a guy locked down i know
he hasn't played ball on you yeah jesus
christ
did you go to corporate or something
what'd you do just drank it
it's pretty good you didn't give it to
her it had seeds in it too which
the pineapples don't have seeds so that
leaves me to believe that a strawberry
or something fell in there
something's alright uh
i i don't know i don't think i've ever
gotten fresh pineapple juice no i don't
drink pineapple juice it makes your uh
semen tastes like pineapple
i heard about that i see that i i want
to be over here i want to be a raw foods
vegan guy i would love to
to have the willpower to do that this is
one of yeah what
you've been saying this for a long time
i'm going vegan i'm going
clean i'm going to the pineapple juice
there's a little steak in there
deep fry for me um yeah i don't know i
just think you gotta make smaller
changes before you
you know go reinventing the wheel that's
all i'm saying but i like that stuff i
know el presidente
over at barstool is big on pineapple
juice ah is that why you do it yeah
guy's a millionaire yeah i mean you know
logically you start drinking what he
drinks
that going for me so my ship's coming in
i just gotta sit back put my feet up
wait for the brink struck to roll into
foleyville
holy's doing pizza reviews for no camera
i like to put the whole pie in my mouth
12 bites
one pie everybody knows your rules
goalie who are you talking about
dad's looking i would have a hard time
doing that and i was probably like i've
never really had
because everything you ate would be a
nine yeah i never have you ever had
have you ever had bad pizza i mean i
guess i have
i don't describe it's i i love all
some some pizza i'm just i'm gonna eat
it or like eat the majority like i'll
eat
every slice of pizza that's put in front
of me whether i like it or not it's
going down especially if i'm hungry
i love pizza yeah i mean sometimes you
get like you know if you've been ever
been like [ __ ] central pa or
something
like that pizza we got when we did
royersford that pizza stunk
that was like bad [ __ ] pizza it was a
palermos too there's a polemos in my
hometown top notch
and i was just like what the [ __ ] like
that was just like i thought i was like
well i have to eat i'm gonna eat it you
know what i mean i'm not gonna go hungry
what am i [ __ ]
can't perform in an empty stomach kippy
needs his [ __ ] carbs you know what i
mean of course what do
it is punchline juice the palermos in my
hometown is so good
that the sun i believe got in trouble
for
doing something shady with some underage
people people still go there
packed the pizza's good enough you
overlook anything
jesus especially your family
if it's all if it ain't on tape i don't
buy it i'm giving him he had two large
pies
uh but that's my opener okay i'm upset
about i was upset about that
it'll ruin your day a little bit yeah
you know what i mean you think like you
know you're on the wavelength you always
go out of the way you tip the guy and
stuff like that
and you give me the [ __ ] you give me
the [ __ ] the fruit buffet
fruit cut me a fresh piney i get it i
get it i can't say i don't get it i
[ __ ] get it it would upset me as well
yeah do you say something do you go yo
buddy
can you cut me a fresh one because we've
been jammed up over here at this deli
when we order food sometimes
and like they try to microwave a panini
i go yo tuts
yeah i ain't paying [ __ ] 11 for no
microwaved [ __ ] chicken porn paneen
throw it in a toaster for your boys
here's the thing me the me
saying things might be in my past
ever since i saw that video of the
couple getting getting whacked over
snow shoveling in pa oh that was tough
that was tough
yeah so my mouth might be shut from here
on out i know i was thinking the pod's
starting to cook i'm not getting i'm not
getting [ __ ] wasted now
well right back a couple months ago i
had nothing to lose you put down like a
dog
yeah if i go i go it goes out on the
street you know what i mean but i'm not
doing that
because everyone's packing once i
squeeze i don't squeeze till it's still
i don't stop squeezing though it's over
you know what i mean
i mean the kid who knows a juice kid
could it could be it could be a [ __ ]
ar-15 behind the counter i don't know
yeah i'm done i'm done
confronting anybody any conference i
just don't care yeah i think it's
whatever
well she was drinking it so dumb
[Laughter]
are you spitting this for me
oh um i had a bit of
uh as we've teased it in i guess on the
last episode we went away
and then you know i went away from my
honeymoon oh no my one year anniversary
we got the whole wrap no we went before
you're redoing materials
i tried it out on the i tried out on the
itunes episode
no so we got to drive i had to drive out
in the middle i woke i didn't know it
was supposed to snow this weekend
remember it snowed sunday morning pretty
heavy and we talked it we talked about
we didn't talk about the drive out there
we we saved it for the podcast big man
we did yeah no but we talked about your
trip with the
you said when did you go out i said
sunday on the on the candy episode
we did the whole thing no we talked
about it on the on the on the family
episode that we just released you had a
[ __ ]
uh a refrigerator in your trunk yeah we
talked about the valet
right yeah and you talked about the trip
a little bit
but we didn't talk about the drive out
there that's crazy no we saved it for
hard feelings
man your car i have a [ __ ] 2019
jeep latitude four-wheel drive without
the attitude
oh that's laddy i love you girl um you
were just to say no to whatever i was
saying
fair enough that i had to drive to the
airport
for when we when we had to go home in
the seat to see the family
um after that big snowstorm i was
terrified just driving on flat surfaces
grand central parkway to the van wyck
not an idiot
um you drove
you're [ __ ] montego and arguably
one of the worst snowstorms in
recent memory liz february has been the
snowiest february
on record yeah and you're driving out to
a [ __ ]
poconos romance weekend i didn't even
know it was supposed to snow we woke up
called like eight o'clock or something
and it's snow and i think it's like
those flurries like
oh look it's snowing type thing you know
what i mean like it's it'll be a it'll
be a dusting
i hop in the shower i get out i'm
packing the bat i'm feeling good i'm
feeling relaxed i'm fighting with foley
for [ __ ] three hours via text
over stuff that doesn't matter um
and remember i'm trying to [ __ ] cooking
my bacon
my eggs and getting it going gonna go
get a cough and it starts [ __ ]
can i stop you sure you're getting in
the car
you're going for a long drive hold on
yeah you're making breakfast before you
leave
that's drive-through excuse right there
that's all we need
yeah i don't want to be 400 pounds oh
okay i mean yeah but trust me i would
love to go get mcmuffins and hash browns
and [ __ ]
and and drink it with fountain sodas in
the morning trust me i want to do that
yeah
it's willpower that i don't my girl's
good on shotgun with fast food
that'll quick with the draw huh yeah
unwraps the burger
[ __ ] nice yeah no i love eating and
driving
[ __ ] double barrel like smith and
wesson right now
i got shotgun driving with my elbows
it's kind
[Laughter]
take the wheel i need a wheel man
um yeah no you're not dude honestly i
would have
been i would have been mad
i didn't didn't put two and two together
what that you [ __ ] drove that car
listen i'm financially linked to you now
yeah okay you're my mommy
at this point no trust me i know um
i gotta keep an eye out i gotta look out
for this kid it was one of those things
where i'm like i didn't know it was
going to snow
right and then like you see the flowers
like oh look it's snowing whatever like
you know it just might be a dusting or
something because
i didn't hear anybody like oh what are
you doing barrel down because thank god
you're right next to the gw it had
snowed a few days before
which i still hadn't dug my car out of
so now i'm getting [ __ ] double-deuced
you thought it was going to be like a
white christmas you're driving out into
the shining
yeah yes yes so i haven't driven in so i
i dig my car out
by the way i get out and someone the guy
behind me is touching my car like
i don't know if the plow pushed him into
me or something he's
literally there's contact with the white
like [ __ ] prius behind me
luckily i got some spot i got some room
up front that i can maneuver so i
what's your equipment with what what are
you scraping this off with
i know it's not proper [ __ ] it's not
it's not it's not
i wanted to save it for the patreon but
like because you would have revealed it
but
it's a full-size broom i have in my car
[Laughter]
i'm just [ __ ] pushing it off yeah
what if the ice builds up how are you
scraping it with the plastic on the end
of the thing
it was not yet he's got a hockey stick
i got a vacuum [ __ ] gretzky out there
left-handed genius the great one i bet
you i bet you're the kind of guy that
doesn't
you you you do the bare minimum on the
scrape i would assume no i like
the defrost through the rest now i'll
set it and forget it no i hit it quick i
got her in the car i said yo tuts hop in
the car and [ __ ]
[ __ ] turn turn it over and start
revving the gas that's real trashy too
would you have somebody in the passenger
seat start in the car
yeah well she couldn't get in because we
were plus so she had to get in the
driver's seat and then hop
over just because we were so plowed in
um
but uh so i cleaned out the car and now
it's like coming down
right like it's like pro it it opened up
on us yeah it was a [ __ ]
it was two nor'easters so meeting
together
completely your [ __ ] neighborhood she
was completely off my [ __ ] doppler
radar dude i didn't have none of that
game across my wire
i don't know what's happening you gotta
get hurricane schwartz on the line so
i [ __ ] we get in the car and now we
go all right we got to pull up and get a
coffee
so we pull up to get she gets she hops
out to get me a coffee
and uh how's the heat in that thing it's
good good heat yeah yeah yeah
ac what ac is a little touchy
i mean in like a heat wave it ain't
gonna do much you're better off with the
windows down
you don't pop the unit in the window i
got a window yeah we think i got the
[ __ ] window
[ __ ] barreling down 84. look about
how cold it would be oh man your battery
would be
in it you only you only need to turn it
on for 20 seconds
man talk about a screaming meme oh full
size ac
yeah let's make ceviche in there
so i start up so we hop in and we get
gas and i realize i'm
hemmed pretty heavy full tank no before
i get gas no
i had to get out i was getting out of
the city so we stopped to get coffee
and i realized it was going to be pretty
[ __ ] dicey
because we were on like a side street
you know we weren't on like a main you
know we'd be on like
kind of the street right next to your
apartment you know not the one out front
like the a little more side street
tough to get out of them and i go to
press the gas and the auto
traction you starts [ __ ] kicking in
like my
all my wheels aren't hitting all [ __ ]
place so i'm like this ride's gonna be
tough
because women because we're going into
the [ __ ] mountains so i'm like it
ain't gonna get any better like if it's
this bad in the city i'm [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] dude
this ain't gonna be good so i'm
tense i am [ __ ] that's a white
knuckle situation and she doesn't
know she's like oh it's okay and i'm
like risk
i'm not worried about what it was at the
moment at the moment i'm like i'm
finding these conditions i'm going
what is this going to be like in an hour
so i got to cross the delaware water gap
you have a scary bridge right now at
some point so it's waiting for you
like the widow maker bridge freezes
before
rotary oh i remember learning that when
i was a kid
i remember my dad telling me that put
the fear of god into it
it all it made perfect sense i don't
know why i just
because there's nothing on the bottom
yeah the air gets under there so
see the moisture gets strapped between
the roadway and what you want to do
hankies
if you're here you got to turn into the
spin yeah
you charge a knife no you charge a gun
you run from a knife turn into a spoon
what'd i say but i've never caught a
fish before you ever been [ __ ]
what did you know about fission um i
forgot about that
so for a movie that i don't like i've
watched the irishman way too many times
so so i started off in the left lane we
get out into like the palisades or
whatever
i ended up in startup i ended up in east
japan
so i started off i'm in the left lane
but then the left lane where
on a highway out of here i don't know in
jersey i'm somewhere in jersey
i get out and i get in new jersey you
get on like the palisades or whatever
head up head
you got the balls and that piece of [ __ ]
to get in the left lane well it was it
was
okay at first right and then as the left
lane because there's less people in it
starts getting you know you can see it
inching in
the snow's inching from the median into
because there's no traction
i know man so i get into the middle lane
and now everybody's in the middle lane
no one's in the left lane and dude we're
nine minutes into the trip and i'm like
this is gonna be how slow are you going
40 i got to keep up with traffic i mean
duped dude by the way there's [ __ ]
jerk offs in like neon employment insane
whipping by i'm like where are you going
that's why when you see you go
50 car pile up in icy conditions i am
stunned the way people [ __ ] drive on
the highway in a snowstorm
when the [ __ ] road's not clear yeah
it [ __ ] blows my mind
um so now it's like you know it starts
off at a foot
into the left lane then two feet then
three feet now it's like crouching in on
the white and i'm going i'm
[ __ ] and she's like can we stop and
get maggots these are like magazines
wait wait wait wait wait a barber shop
honey we might not even make it
and then i was thinking i'm like this is
attractive magazines to read when we get
to the spotlight when she's like
relaxing at the spa or whatever
so you're gonna need a cup of coffee i'm
like
i'm like ladies we're going to pull
we're going to carton of bernie's and
[ __ ]
you got to be like you got to be like
paulie's girl with these things and
[ __ ] johnny on the spot with no
chains
that masseuse is going to break their
hands on your cement back
so she goes have you been under any
stress
yeah i just made dead man's run with
this broad reading us weekly next to me
i went face to face with old man's bluff
and he blew
because she's finding out where kate
beckinsale gets her yogurt from
ironically it's the same place foley
with the pineapple
screw doc you'll never believe this
million to one shot it's in the story of
queens
stop and get dude in those situations i
tell her
don't say a [ __ ] don't don't say a
word to me
jesus shut up and she's like you're a
[ __ ]
psycho i literally i'm like yeah but i'm
gonna get you there a lot that's what
i'm
and and all that also too they don't get
it they tell she
she's got her feet on the dashboard i'm
like [ __ ] airbag you [ __ ] put your
knees halfway to your [ __ ] what are
you doing
put your head between your legs she's
got one of those legs she's smiling her
nails and shovels
oh my god i feel like i'm driving a tank
dude
i feel like i'm driving into a [ __ ]
blitzkrieg you got a life preserver on
i got one of the oxygen masks like an
airplane
he's driving the memphis bell over here
oh
no radio if it is it's [ __ ] it's it's
news radio
on am i want the real story i i don't
need that serious xm
i don't care what's going on i don't
omaha i don't need no fluff piece
give me the hard news on the eights
ladies and gentlemen get off the roads
get off the roads batten down the
hatches especially if you're in a 2006
five mercury montego yeah i don't need
some [ __ ] well-dressed [ __ ] hip
guy giving me the scoop with a smile on
his face
i want you some hard noise beat reporter
you're telling me how it is on this
iron glass we're tanking over here
zipping you're doing 90 in a golf cart
in a blizzard
well my car is a tank it's a big [ __ ]
car
that's even worse the tires on that
thing no but it's heavy it's
you want the heaviness those tires are
bolder than you are
pretty good teemo taking shots at the
boss huh it's coming out here paint
jacket
dude i'm mid-headed too i'm throwing
rocks he's got a couple in him at happy
hour
he's about to take a [ __ ] run at the
boss
had the young bull
you're nuts so i also i did but now she
goes
i'm leaving my phone at the house
because it's like a relaxation weekend
and
you're also i want to get into it you're
not allowed to really have them out at
the thing you know what i mean it's like
a
disconnect it's a disconnection from
like the outside world a little bit
you know for your mind body and soul
type thing so she's like i'm just gonna
leave it at the house i go okay
but now we're [ __ ] i'm using it for
gps because i don't know where i'm going
so i need to turn by turn unless i can
you don't have to set up
i do have the setup oh yeah i got i got
the window john yeah
thank god so but she's like she's like
how long is it supposed to snow i go
i don't know and we can't look it up
because you don't have yourself like
you don't have your cell phone and we
can't you can't start google and stuff
on mine because i don't know where i'm
going i can't
i know it's going to snow three years
from now
i got that [ __ ] locked everybody's got a
phone they're charged there's water
there's a flashlight
i got flares the whole nine yards at
that point i still thought it was going
to be like
when i we left the house there's gonna
be flurry you know just like whatever
[ __ ] dude i'm in the middle of this you
got shorts in hawaii
come on i want to lay it on your nose
dude i ended up in a squall dude this
thing was tough so
so if we pull up the gate now i gotta
wait now legend lives on from
one so it's also that thing where it's
like all right now i gotta start
i gotta make sure my cell phone's ch
plug
charge in case we go off the road and i
i gotta make sure i have battery
well thank god i got boots on you know
buck knife and some snow shoes
i got a can of gas and some sardines we
can live for three weeks she's trying to
she's on relaxing weekend dip yeah
you're in the revenant
tom hardy's closing in on your six she's
reading people magazine and you're like
i wonder if i could eat her
yeah i'm trying to
if i can burn those papers i can get a
fire hot enough to cook her
oh [ __ ] um so
we you would have remembered talking
about this wouldn't you
uh so we pull over to get gas and in
jersey they pump your gas so i pull up
and the guy
it's so the weather so bad he went home
dude he ain't nowhere to be found so i'm
like honking and
you can't just start you need like a key
to start the fight excuse me my good man
he comes out he's like what the [ __ ] are
you doing
he's like go home dude it ain't worth it
oh i thought this was going to be a
snoozer wrap too
he's like what are you oh he's looking
at me i'm like 30. that 25 dude
i don't wanna because if we pull oh if
we get if we gets jammed up i don't want
all the gas in the car
dude do you know what's bad wait wait
wait wait wait if you get jammed up you
don't want a lot of gas in the car
that's an extra five bucks i need in my
pocket you guys are gonna pay a tow
truck driver or something
i don't know i'm just you want to have a
full tank because you get stuck
i know but the the weight too you need
to wait to keep this guy in the way
i wish i had you in the car
stop my grandpa hey babe does it get
pretty bad i'm gonna circle back and
grab the big man
where you folks heading i'm like the
specialist
[Music]
he's got a bag of white castle burgers
[Laughter]
i'll get you there happy anniversary
folks i got it from here
tie him to the roof like a christmas
tree
make a lot i left i said
bowling as you're looking at there they
good man
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you got you've got goggles and a scarf
like an old-timey pilot
riding stage goats i'm just hanging on
my burgers
[Laughter]
you good big man i got you kippy
he got a long hauler about two miles
ahead looks like a rookie
stay to the right this guy's all over
the road
i never lost her man on an expedition oh
my [ __ ] back hurts man
everything earth oh this can't be
healthy what are you doing
the cash gas station guy wanted no parts
of pumping my gas dude you gotta abandon
the trip when the sherpas are taking off
i know well she's like yeah no [ __ ] man
yeah the billy goats are going the other
way
that's like when the birds all start
flying
all the plows are going the other way
i'm like what the [ __ ] that was always
my thing with that tsunami
people were like the [ __ ] ocean
pulled out three miles
people are hey you stuck around to check
out the coral reefs
it's like buddy hop on a tram car and
hit the bridge meanwhile the dog's
shaking his knees are pretty [ __ ] in
the street
[ __ ] run wow what are you doing
so you guess up so we grab some snacks
gas up
she's like do you think they have
magazines i'm like lady off i can't kill
you i think they have meg they think
you're gonna have a [ __ ] magazine
so um
i still can't google where it's going to
be worse how much worse it's going to
get
what time it's supposed to snow i don't
know anything i'm just know i'm driving
into the mountains and a squall you
think the tennis court is over
wait i have a real important question
what's the refund policy on this trip
there i mean there is none there is no
ritz yeah oh that was my dad
we're going into it yeah so
oh god so we start cruising
and now the middle lane where we are is
kaput that's all it's snow like you know
it was at least like
that's the situation you'd rather be in
traffic where everyone's driving that's
why i was like i want to get
i want to follow somebody you know what
i mean i want someone clearing their way
sir are you a real man i need a what if
i scooch in
i need a nose tackle or a fullback or
something
[ __ ] cleared a pathway for the teague
guys playing smash mouth football over
here right up the middle
that [ __ ] deuce daily right up the
gut none of that west coast [ __ ]
did you say smash mouth football yeah
and so we called it back in the day
oh so we [ __ ] so now
i'm feeling like okay it's whatever it's
it's worsening the sim
you know the the scene is getting dude i
was it was like [ __ ] dark at eight
o'clock in the morning yeah it was great
by noon it was great
it was great i was like even if it was
snowy it would be okay
so by the way you were driving illegally
all the roads
there was a state of emergency in new
jersey and pennsylvania not at that
moment
i had about 20 minutes yeah i mean it
was does that mean meanwhile people were
passing me like i was they're giving me
the look
what's this guy doing so
um i uh so then at one point
we gotta get on i don't [ __ ] know the
thruway or 84 or something
so we're riding with a group of people
you don't want to be on 84. everybody
goes right
and i'm the only guy going
and i was like i'm like this ain't
guessing that's so much home
last time i saw me peeled off a left
that makes me nervous i i
when that's it i was like i looked at
her i got it the wrong way i even said i
said that a lot ago this ain't good
i like the way you just i gotta thank
god because it wasn't like meant to take
it just came out and it was like i was
it was like
it was like a perfect store i was
looking at that big wave over like
capsizing the boat i'm like this ain't
gonna be good for business
and she goes what i go i don't like
leading the charge i don't like being
the first man
in i'm now i'm now blazing the trail for
the like
there's like one corolla behind me a few
clicks he ain't gonna make it out he
ain't gonna make it
he don't have the weight he was dead
before he got in the car
so it then subsides a little bit
it slows down it doesn't get any worse
it slows a bit it's still snowing
the flakes gets they get you the flakes
get smaller which it was always to me
when they get smaller i mean there's a
lot more in store that was always the
bigger they get them the sooner it's
going to stop
that was always i don't know if it's a
myth or though i heard yeah
schwartz tell me that i don't know we're
getting dumped on
and the [ __ ] windshield wipers
aren't fantastic they were back at the
house
they're back with the guy at the gas
station warming up out of fire
so i it's a thing to keep the heat going
i got to have the back defrosters on i
don't know how the headlights look can i
jump in there body i'm right here that
defrost
and the snow and the uh the wipers
will [ __ ] you they get like streaky
drives yes that's it
you have to keep hitting the juice which
you don't got a lot
i got water no i got juice cool there's
something wrong with the connection
where it don't come out i got
bad guns slinging ecto cooler yeah i got
bad guns
squirting the other way it doesn't even
go i don't know where it goes it's not
even getting to the base
clown flower um
so yeah that's that's not a thing that's
bad so it's you know
so now i'm letting the snow fall on the
windshield to moisten it up so i can
clean it real quick
you know and then because it dries out
so i got to let it get
yeah that's what i'm saying so i gotta
let that to solve that instead of spray
i let the snowflakes gather up a bit
then i wash them off real quick
i was i was wrong i was like unsafe yeah
i was i was wrong i was flying blind for
a little bit
so all and then it flashed in my head i
go this is like
what you hear about comedian
[ __ ] finally gets like budding
comedian and finally gets successful
yeah honeymoon anniversary driving for a
one-night spa
getaway drives off the side of a cliff
hit by a [ __ ] tractor trail and i'm
going i'm
this is this is in print already and
that's why when you asked me
on the episode that we just did yeah
when you said oh it's your birthday i
said
i didn't give you a date i said it out
it's at the end of the month because
it's always
two days before his birthday three days
after his birthday so
you don't think the universe knows your
birthday i don't know i just don't like
also hold on i'm not giving him a shot i
gotta say there was a youtube comment i
believe
where you remember how foley did the
knock on his head and the five dollar
you know when he does something wrong
he's got a or the five the ayg
whatever um he was knocking it and
wiping it knocking away somebody because
he looks like a third base coach telling
you to steal home
[Laughter]
home run um so it lightens up it
subsides a little bit
and the sun comes out i'm on the greener
panel nice look at you
as we get into pa it's not as bad like
it's kind of
it stops and we stop i get a [ __ ] six
here to sneak
into the [ __ ] hotel not for the ride
to take for the hotel
you stopped we stopped yeah once it
cleared off i go i gotta [ __ ] it i gotta
get i gotta get a pack of burnies i
gotta [ __ ] take a leak i gotta
reassess some [ __ ] you know what i mean
i'm not stopping in the middle of that
thing are you out of the woods now
uh what do you mean out of the woods
like go ahead keep going yeah like i
mean
weather-wise we're fine okay so we get
the highways are clear like because it's
not coming down as much and people are
driving so it's you know it's
kind of like like it's just rained or
whatever i'm still got my head on a
[ __ ] swivel you know what i mean i'm
checking my six
charlie's still out there
[Laughter]
kimmy's got a trucker hat was born to
kill
you got a confederate flag on my back so
we
we get going but now the then we get
into like the fight we get off and now
we're in the mountain town i don't i
don't like that man
and they're not plowed on they all got
suv they're like snow people you know
they might as well be [ __ ] yetis
hey chewbacca just grab a shovel and hit
the walkway
why don't you throw some [ __ ] salt
behind my back tires i'm stuck right now
i thought they smell bad
on the outside
so we [ __ ] uh
so the back roads getting there was dice
it was like i was all over the place and
it was those things where i'm like
cruising down a hill and i'm like all
right if someone's coming around this
bend it's gonna be tough
and then also they're gonna be a
10-speed race
so like it was like all right i gotta
lay on it going down this hill because i
got to get up a hill because there's
weird rules with that it's like a
rollercoaster momentum you can't slam on
the brakes my dad taught me
you got to pump the brakes pumped up
yeah you got to pump the brakes like
toby said you have to turn into a spin
but i don't know when i'm spinning well
i don't know what's going on which i'm
which way he's left which way is right i
don't know yeah
i think you're gonna say something oh no
oh okay um
so okay uh fully signed into snowstorm
he's like there'll be a documentary
about me i'll finally get a tv credit
you can't put a gun to my head man
the most earnest response the screeching
halt was brought to you by the chicamo
chicago comedy scene chicamo
what the hell was that and i had
multiple tv credits
it wasn't even accurate that's why he
stood that's why he sniffed it because
you said he didn't have any tv credits
that's why he didn't laugh at you
one last night what are you talking
about
they're not gonna drink all over this
[ __ ] run the clip
they cut my lines
it looked like you paused for a second
uh i think he was about to say something
then lost confidence in the
was that what you were going to say when
you paused no i
i'm i had a good one i'm no i'm i'm
editing so i
just i just yeah i saw a movement and i
looked and we caught eyes and it was
like a deer in the headlights
oh god um so we finally get you know we
get there
um and uh all is well that [ __ ]
i mean then i told you on the itunes
episode about the [ __ ] on the family
up about the
valet which was embarrassing
embarrassing
but i did something fun i did have so
it's also you're supposed to check out
um you're supposed to check out
completely a [ __ ] you know you're not
a lot of you
they don't tell you you're not a lot of
your cell phones like this is like a
relatively technology-free
place like don't be on your [ __ ]
speaker phones don't be
because they didn't have wi-fi no this
play i'm dude this was this ended up
costing me like a [ __ ] trip to you it
was a lot of
well costing her a trip to europe a lot
of quiche very nice and it's the dude
i i knew it was going to be nice because
i popped into like the bathroom on the
first floor this is how you know we're
trashy too
so it's a spa right and check-in's not
till like three but they're like you're
allowed to come early
and use the services all day and use the
facilities all day yeah
i'm there at eight a.m we were there a
[ __ ] ten [ __ ] yeah
so early check-in is it ready let's go
what dude so they go we'll get your bags
we'll text you when your room's ready
your bags will already be in your room
by the time you go back to your room
like when we text you you don't have to
do anything we're just letting you know
it's ready whenever you want to come by
so when you get your keys your bags
already in your room
what do you change to put your like your
shorts on and stuff like that there's a
locker room that
would be like presidential because you
know it's fancy
because part of the locker room is
carpeted and there's like couches and
stuff in there
yeah all like oakland golf course yes
nothing like a country club locker room
dude you could like you could [ __ ]
take a towel off the stack wipe your ass
or throw it on the ground by the time
you look someone's replaced the towel
and another guy picked that one up
really and it was so limited there was
only like
i don't know maybe 15 20 people using
the whole facility
yeah it's a [ __ ] blizzard outside i
know but i was i mean because it's like
you know limited
stain or whatever sure so buddy i was a
king of the [ __ ] castle but there was
these broads there
birds couple of birds and
they're like oh the whole place is you
know cell phone free like we
you know try to keep we're trying not to
have you [ __ ] celebrate it if you
want to take a picture or whatever but
don't be playing music
talking on [ __ ] face time and all
this [ __ ]
it's also you're supposed to be there to
relax sure unplug
unwind get a [ __ ] massage dude these
this broad
brought her cell phone charger to the
pool
like there's like a big indoor thing and
she's charging it
she's standing in like this most
tranquil place
oh what a guy next to the wall charging
her phone
and i'm like what are we doing here like
this isn't you're supposed to be talking
on it yelling no just
[ __ ] whatever another person so
there's an outdoor hot tub probably like
the size of this
room i saw that yeah that's what's nice
with the snow that's something i've
always wanted that's why i was like i'm
glad it's [ __ ] snowing because we got
to hang out
yeah always wanted to do that it was
it's
it's i'm always weird how that works
rich people are you cold up top
yeah but in a good way yeah yeah i open
the window when i'm taking a shower in
the winter that's the closest thing i
ever came here
[Applause]
to drift uh yeah it's real clear it's
very nice very classy but then also too
so
good for the skin too we this is how i
knew we were trashy because we got there
like 11 the one that like to be
you're you're garbage but you're not tr
that broad is trash that's trash
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm garbage because
we check did she even get in there
we checked in that morning at 11 and
didn't leave to like 7 p.m the next
night because you get it the whole next
day too
really and you don't get to pay so
during the week even after you check out
yeah they'll check out your bags we'll
put them in your car they send someone
up they grab
everything out of your outfit don't you
have to get oh you bring it maybe keep a
bag to change and
they give you a bag they give you they
give you a bag for the wheat and they
keep it
oh really yeah you keep the bag what is
it it's like a
canvas bag or whatever herschel no this
is how also i knew
we were [ __ ] trash because my girl's
like i think they'll know if we steal
the robes but they were [ __ ]
i mean yeah then that dude like putting
they were like rough on the outside like
you would want like you would see them
you know like the stitching kind of sure
inside was like velvet oh body it was
fantastic you're walking around your
little stinger hanging out naked
no you gotta you got trunks trunks yeah
yeah yeah okay um
these bro and then like so there's like
a an outdoor
hot tub this big right um and if there's
one other person you're allowed in it
like you but she's got to stay over like
you they got to see that you're a girl
no like out
outside of your traveling sure um so
there was this woman in it and
uh she's like you can get in if you want
because the guy like you're by herself
yeah she's by herself
um she's like you can get in if you want
i'm gonna menage a kippy
i'm over here so i'm like okay so uh
where's your girl
at this point i think she was getting a
treatment done or sauna or something
because it's guys and girls what do you
mean so like the guys have their own
locker room their own sawing of their
own hot tub
even the outdoor one no the outdoors
community so there's like a communal
park
a coed part but inside the guys have
like their own hangout room
they have their own locker room they
have their own hot tub their sauna
steam room that's the waters where
you're on vacation yeah you know let it
go
there's a male and female entrance to
each like to the spot it's very
very cool uh so i'm out there and dude
we're in this [ __ ] we're in that hot tub
and it's snowing and she's on facetime
and she's like yeah i'm just like up
here at the [ __ ] thing and i want to
be like
what are we doing i would have easily
said what are we doing
but it's also like then uh that's just
gonna
anger me for all day because i'd be like
i should have said this i would have
said that you know
that's just you're gonna think that
anyway i know but i just go oh she's
[ __ ] stupid like i can just like oh
she's a piece of [ __ ] and move on from
there
but like dude she's sitting there like
yeah we're here you're not [ __ ]
anything i'm like
why are we even you here for social what
are you here for like instagram likes
it's crazy i mean i was i was getting
some [ __ ] traffic on instagram
it was doing [ __ ] pulling digits
living it up
yeah that's what i was thinking what
would schultz do yeah you'll be posting
about his cool thing
yeah yeah but also like i had to have
the six pack
i got a stop they got a sixer you got
the sixer in the hot tub with you
no can't do that no but i mean i got the
sixer in the hotel room in the second
sink can you grab a cocktail at the bar
and go outside and sit at the in the hot
tub yeah yeah
plastic cups they could do plastic yeah
yeah
it doesn't like it tell you what you
would think it's not but an ipa in a
plastic cup
ice cold it's clean living i don't hate
it yeah dude cold beer
cold beer hot tub not too cheap yeah
it's [ __ ] buddy i'm telling you i was
so relaxed i was i was like nothing will
ever bother me ever again toby's killing
me
um but i did have honestly i mean it
could have been the ipa's talking
because at that point i was about seven
or eight of them deep
uh i had to get drunk with nothing to do
nothing to do but relax is there
anything better and then it was like in
the morning i get up and i [ __ ]
steamed
oh get that out of here i never get all
the [ __ ] sweat out of you yeah get
all these
fits oh it's great dude love a steamer
it's great shout out to my buddy phil
who introduced me to the place and they
go he's got cash they go for the weekend
i know phil they go
because it's minimum there's a two-night
minimum on the weekend
which i can't [ __ ] swing would have
been [ __ ] 35 grand i can't do that
and she rolling up on a sunday yeah
hence me rolling up on a sunday in a
snowstorm
yeah we were all weekend so we're gonna
have to get some magazines but i mean i
was there for like
almost 48 hours sure you know got my
money's worth
stole some products some samples yeah
yeah
did you get a massage or anything i
think i got i got a gentleman's facial
did you yeah fantastic we already talked
about it
i don't know if we did i've had one
before too but i was drunk
yeah it was fantastic but i did want to
get into this is kind of i had the best
meal i've ever had i wanted to ask you
best meal i've ever because you had said
that they had they had a burger that you
wanted to check out i know when i got a
hold of that grass feder i
[ __ ] up because i thought it was also
going to be uh the
i thought it would be on the i thought
it was on the dinner menu but it was
only on the lunch menu so i saw it on
the launch i didn't pull the trigger
no burgers on the dinner menu oh dude
this place puts you
to and also it's a no cash place so i
but then i was there and a guy goes i
sit down on my first meal right
and there's like what's your first meal
lunch lunch that day we got there hit
the spa
you can eat your robes they encourage it
[ __ ] sit down
like a dude they give you they give you
15 pieces of silver i don't even know
what to do at all it was like an erector
set right in the pocket yeah i didn't
know what to do with it it was [ __ ]
rolled up in a napkin like it looked
like a [ __ ]
like a dora flame log
so so i sit down and the guy goes john
come here and john comes over and he he
hits john with
not a one i don't know it had 20 20 vibe
to it you know what i mean it wasn't a
like
it wasn't it was it was a 20 vibe it's
like oh [ __ ] am i supposed to be tipping
this broad on all the [ __ ] happening
no like so i google it do you tip here
and it was no no no no everything was on
the everything's they whack you at the
end and they get you they get you yeah
don't worry about it
oh really yeah they get you at the end
dude you go into a place with a nice
tablecloth it's like trading places
you're like i don't know what's going on
i don't know what to do this is what i'm
saying like i can acclimate but i gotta
look around to make sure i'm doing the
right
thing you know i can play along but i'm
making sure i'm i'm i know the rules
start on the outside work your way in
yeah always always so
i mean but they also had it when you
unrolled it it r it uh
it unraveled that way well like a
[ __ ]
shaving kit nah but they weren't it was
just like every time you did it it fell
the right way oh i know exactly what
you're talking about you know what i
mean like
there was two knives there was a spoon
and there was three four napkins
you're about to torture someone in
guantanamo i know that's what i'm
thinking about a pair of pliers
build a butcher over here not like i'm
about to start boosting cars or
something
which i uh which i did try some of the
door the handles on the mercedes
um and uh any hotties up there
yeah older crowd oh no i mean yeah
30s 40s and then like you know it was
all over all over the map not a lot of
eye candy
i had the ha i had i had the best game
of the lot really yeah which felt pretty
good it felt pretty good
yeah yeah she's a racehorse now right
really is a nice bob what do you mean
beautiful girl kibby's got a sunday
night 10. yeah
it was nice it was nice to be walking
like i was catching eyes people could
catch her and then catch me suits
bathing suits yeah
two-piece one piece me her
guys you can't teach your stuff you
can't i'm sorry this is what you're
paying for right here
and you don't get this guy we got your
money's worth for the year on this
episode
uh was she wearing a two-piece yeah
really yeah
she's your opinion she's like you had
anything
pennsylvania not transylvania let's go
put those things away will
oh you that was a flat transylvania line
it was fine
[ __ ] but i threaded the needle with
that thing come on
it should have got more it was too quick
it was it was quick and a tinker a
little bit too good
kimmy's in a speedo in a robe really i'm
in the pool of my robe
can i just imagine your robe instantly
having mustard stains on it
no i don't [ __ ] with mustard i don't
like top goddamn it i ruined my hot dog
hey don't touch that robe i got beers in
there
[Music]
you got the party mix from the bar
you're eating it right out of the rope
pocket
really she's prancing around in a bikini
good for you i'm serious i mean yeah
i can see that i'm sure you can weirdo
i'm sure you have a couple of times if i
can close your eyes
take it a pleasure town
ah that's a good feeling um oh
god i don't even know where i was um
it was just treating them a lot it was
fantastic
but then you feel a little
self-conscious you know the guys are
peeking at her
yeah i don't care and i'm sure there had
to be some other guys in there you know
i'm yeah i caught them they look i
i mean i'm you know she's attractive on
me
just think they probably thought you
were rich and then or a big beeping
[ __ ] overdue
they're probably telling they're laying
in bed at night well he's probably
packing
wrong he's probably loaded wrong well
they see your bulge in the [ __ ]
in the in the in the bathing suit when
you gotta all that i wore the sheath
just to give myself an extra [ __ ]
inch or two
i got two pair of sheets on wearing them
backwards too
confuse you a little bit but you imagine
some guy sees you getting into the
montego on the way out
you ruined that guy's life he probably
went home got a divorce he's like what
am i doing wrong
yeah what [ __ ] the [ __ ] that guy doing
my wife's paying for it so check out
she's signing for everything look at the
guy's dick i think that's an all-day ipa
look at this deck is that a ninny this
guy's got a founders
[Laughter]
van look at you good for you
all right the meal your first meal of
the day
first meal i took pictures of the menu
so we can we can play a little bit oh
what
beautiful yeah prices on there oh
everything's on the cuff
you can order anything you want uh yeah
how many
what how many can you get no you can't
order it's not a buffet
you get a meal like a prefix oh it's a
prefix okay
um so you can't order like a couple
different appetizers i'll tell you one
thing i'm sure you could but he added to
the room go ahead
yeah ain't sharon they're not sharing
i'll tell you that much
no wait because they're weirdos correct
yeah yeah
we share with our ladies she wanted to
share i didn't yeah dude it's nice
couple there is nothing better than than
having a couple of drinks and sharing an
appetizer with with
the person you love right t-bone half a
fried chicken sandwich half a burger oh
yeah get out of here she's gonna finish
it we don't have
um all right just for time
because we gotta get we gotta get boogie
anyway um
where are we at we're 52. yeah cool okay
let's do this um all right this is for
dinner i only took dinner
all right um dinner how many courses
uh four i guess
entree salad uh
main dessert there's no appetizer
i'm sorry appetizer salad entree dessert
that's pretty good can you get soup or
salad you get both you get a salad
regardless regardless read the menu
first choice of one
creamy chicken soup cauliflower cream
free range chicken rosemary biscuit fine
herbs by the way everything's farm to
table farm on the property
what yeah farm on the [ __ ] property
that you walk to they got rosemary
lobster mac and cheese delon still i
don't know
dylantellini pasta you can stop at the
lobster mac and cheese that's it
that is the trashiest rich person food
caulking
calkins creamy three cheese fondue
crispy brussels sprouts caramelized
sweet potato fine herbs
that's in the mac and cheese on top like
crusted on the top that was the crust
was shredded
[ __ ] brussels sprouts and i was like
what is this i've had it before i don't
know what it is
i've never had it in this form what kind
of beans are these
um my girl and which spoon do i use
sesame and tree juice maple syrup hit
the bricks i don't know what that is
uh roasted radish uh this is a separate
dish
separation oh no that's a sesame tree
wait sesame and tree juice maple syrup
roasted rash
yeah yeah so you for sure got the
lobster mac and cheese yeah
two lobster max also by the way when
they go because my girl's doing
gluten-free for
like medical reasons they go is anybody
gluten-free or any food allergies i told
him on the phone when we
i said yeah my wife is gluten free
everything came out adjusted or
what no mac uh they used gluten-free
whatever really yeah on hers damn
yeah and then they were like they they
came over and dropped bread
and then the wait the waitress came back
and she goes
i completely forgot um because they you
just tell them what room you are and
they know that [ __ ] my wife is
she ever fired no she goes she came back
out two seconds later
cause my my wife because i wish i could
have like i would kill for a roll
two seconds later she came back she goes
uh i i forgot to tell the chef that you
were gluten free
we didn't tell her they just know in our
files she goes i forgot to tell you were
gluten-free
they just fired a gluten-free roll for
you real [ __ ]
you crushed the rest of the basement i
got i did that whole basket daddy oh
yeah
keep the butter coming this ain't gonna
cut it
how are they serving the butter uh due
to covid it was in like uh
like a small uh small ramekin
yeah but a tiny like a low rimmed we're
not like a regular ramen but like a
ramekinish dish
with cellophane on it and like a creamy
thing but they had to have cellophane no
covet i bet that's coming out like
like looking like a flower or something
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah they just got it
for cova they got a
they gotta crush it up sometimes um okay
roasted tomato caprese salad
okay um and then salad a regular you
could order a regular salad for one sure
house salad balsamic vinaigrette i'm
sure
entrees here we go the money maker
free-range chicken breast marsala
nope white miso marinated chilean sea
bass which i
wanted to get my hands on maybe stop
leading us stop bleeding us we gotta
guess
uh root vegetable crusted diver sea
scallops
okay no shot vegetable bowl bolognese
zero percent chance okay prime 10 ounce
new york strip steak we're getting close
let me run down that for you peter
wilcox potato poutine black truffle
cheese curds charred baby carrots
roasted uh
roman seco broccolini red wine
demi-glace glaze
and compound butter it was [ __ ]
out dude i took one i moaned when i uh
when i ate it was
so good dude oh that's what you got
that's what i got there's no fillet
but no no filet butter it changes every
day new york strip huh new york strip
menu changes every day
all three meals the steak can't be farm
to table
i guess the steak is and i guess all the
i would assume all the produce is
sure i mean i doubt they're you know
killing the cow next to the [ __ ] sig
hut i was in
and then a butternut squash and herb
risotto oh
man i love [ __ ] risotto it's pretty
good that's on the side with the steak
no that's another whole maine or is it
depends if you're tipping desserts
camera uh caramel apple cheesecake
chocolate raspberry tart
pumpkin creme brulee vegan orange almond
ginger cake
did you at least get two different
desserts yeah we got
i believe we did the caramel apple
cheesecake and the chocolate raspberry
tart
didn't go for the creme brulee rookie
moves i don't know what she did
she might have did the cur the creme
brulee that would make sense the
cheesecake and
she's taking the creme brulee i can't
remember i was at this point i was
[ __ ]
11 ipas deep and the beers keep coming
yeah you pay for the beers at checkout i
found out
[ __ ] nine bucks a clip um i only had
10.
yeah he's lying yeah but it was [ __ ]
fancy pain oh i got this for you i want
to do that we'll run through this real
quick
i got breakfast you dude this is this
would be
well we were in hawaii we did one nice
breakfast at this hotel
and it was literally dude it was just
eggs bacon
hash browns and toast it was like 30
bucks yeah
we just did one day every every other
day was just you know either musabi or
something like that which is fantastic
but just that simple stuff dude i didn't
[ __ ] about the price
at all it was so [ __ ] good just
simple
and done well i love it uh so you you
get a
you got a drink right like uh they have
ju like
juices oh you know sweet sunrise
juice selection chef smoothie you can
get coffee organic teas whatever
that's all in the cup if you get well
fresh squeezed juice um
now that it means choice of one smoked
ham
and caulkins creamery cream creamery
cheddar omelette
i guess caulking creamery is there you
know
uh open-faced egg white omelet two farm
eggs fried or scrambled
organic sweet potato cow butternut
squash hash
oh it sounds good that was that's what
the broad god wasn't too
shabby belgian waffle they're trash
again that
stuffed crepes and homemade strawberry
chia seed jam not bad
not too shabby where's the eggs benny
open-faced colossal crab
eggs benedict
[Laughter]
if you're getting anything with jumbo or
colossal in it
is like uh that's like i don't know
something that's what they say yeah
that's what godzilla thought
posted english muffin poached eggs black
more forms green
spa hollandaise sauce breakfast blt
hot steel cut oatmeal spa powder bowl
power bowl
toasted bagel locks three breakfast
skillet scramble
then on the sides then you get your
sides choice of
not one you're firing me up here not one
not two
but three choices sides we're talking
breakfast potatoes turkey sausage
history smoked
hickory smoked bacon bagel with cream
cheese that's what i got
my wife goes eggs by the dick and a
bagel with cream cheese so check your
mouth to pay for it giovanni nonfat
greek yogurt
housemate granola bonnie yeah what the
[ __ ]
i don't know get some fagier at this
dump will you mix fresh fruit breakfast
breads or
toasts love lettuce we said three each
listen i'm a huge fan of the breast the
bread the breakfast
bread basket yeah a little apple butter
good i'm telling you it was [ __ ] if
you got
15 grand you should go to this place for
a couple of hours
it's a [ __ ] home run it was great wow
best uh the nicest place i've ever been
to for sure
must be nice must be nice
tune in next time for the polar opposite
holy ghost holy ghost down ashore for a
nuclear stress test
tell your story about me my girlfriend
will fight in the grocery store
because i'm trying to get pop tarts gang
this has been
an exciting episode of the hard feelings
uh we'll come back next time
we'll talk about uncle hank's nuclear
stress desk because i'm not talking i'm
not popping [ __ ] colossal jumbo ipas
or whatever he did uh we love you and
we'll see you next time peace